tout commence le 6 mars 2010 est un coup
de tonnerre dans le milieu médical
un des anesthésistes les plus réputés de
besançon est accusé du pire
le docteur frédéric péché est suspecté
d'avoir sciemment empoisonné sept de ses
patients deux d'entre eux sont décédés
les autres souffrent de séquelles
neurologiques graves mises en examen
placé sous contrôle judiciaire
le médecin de 46 ans ne peut plus
exercer son métier suis innocent de tout
ce qui est de tout ce qui est de toutes
les accusations à mon encontre
commence alors une longue instruction où
il apparaît que des poches d'hydratation
ont été pollués avec du potassium à dose
létale le mobile
glaçant du pompier pyromane apparaît le
docteur aurait provoqué des malaises
chez des patients pour mieux les sauver
une thèse repoussé par ses avocats qui
évoque images à l'appui un complot
fomenté contre lui par un autre
professionnel
un an plus tard la justice ouvre une
seconde enquête
une quarantaine de cas suspects dont la
moitié mortels sont explorées un
minutieux travail d'expertisé qui
débouche sur l'exhumation de quatre
corps dans le jura en décembre dernier
un chapitre de plus dans cette affaire
inédite en france par le nombre de
victimes envisagée